after coming home from a long trip a
valley family discovered their apartment
was overgrown with black mold and that
they had a roach infestation eight news
now investigates as the family is now
forced out of their home
latoya barnes her husband dante gilmer
and their three young children were
forced to leave their apartment and
everything they own after the place was
completely infested with black mold this
happened in the central valley at the
university gardens apartments north of
flamingo road and university center
the family says it's not a safe place to
stay as the mold has grown over the
walls and floor and roaches have
infested the entire unit barnes claims
the mold was there before and she asked
the complex to fix it but says they
never did and once they left for a
three-week trip it got out of control we
reached out to the apartment complex in
a statement they said in part westland
university gardens takes all appropriate
actions to provide a safe community and
environment for our residents
maintenance technicians staff and
vendors
they also claim that barnes did not
allow them to enter the apartment
without her there and said when they
told her the unit was no longer livable
she became quote angry and belligerent
she then proceeded to verbally and
physically assault the management staff
end quote the company said it wants to
resolve the issue as soon as possible
barnes had another version of that
confrontation and said she was trying to
keep office staff at a distance during a
heated argument she says she is now
speaking with an attorney for that full
statement and a closer look at this
story head to our website eight newsnow
dot com